en vous promenant dans la rue vous avez
sûrement aperçu ces sorte de gaufre à la
forme étonnante voire dérangeante se
coincent à ces sucreries en forme de
zizi ou demi nous sortent tout droit
d'un lieu appelé la coquetterie témoins
il est venu tout droit de thaïlandais
qui a vu le jour en france au moment du
premier confinement pour tenter de
booster les ventes d'un restaurant à
paris donc un message j'allais faire
parler d'elle fort de son succès le
concept s'est exporté à travers la
france on peut donc retrouver ces
sucreries coquilles à montpellier
toulouse est désormais à angers mais
dans la ville tout le monde ne raffole
pas de la quéquette puisqu'une pétition
a été signée pour faire interdire
l'ancien qui est à 200 mètres d'une
école et d'un lycée catholique alors
selon vous faut-il interdire les gaufres
en forme de quéquette
voile alors faut-il interdire les kékés
trichet
n'a pas été réglée sur celle de kata
et qu'ils en font aussi des mini
jeux blizzard
c'est bon
ça n'est pas la même non hanouna evala
goûter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je diabétiques
sont nés la pâtisserie française et ses
raisons que vous avez à quelques
chiffres
je bois je me suis résigné au foot par
exemple ou dessin se composerait -
thomas jane j'en ai une la
faute sûrement très bien sassus vous
vous non c'est bien mais je
n'ai pas vu à sioniste foot comme ça
excusez moi mais c'est quand même super
et je reconnais
mais avec comme castaldi va pas regarder
je vois nos image vaut bien quelques uns
très gros cette semaine non mais ça
c'est la salle et c'est bien fait mais
c'est un succès
mais au jeu pas bernard montiel eux
j'en avais de alors oui j'aimerais bien
sûr qu'il faut les interdire montre
des chiens mâles rapport mais je
comprends pas on est dans une époque on
passait notre temps à mettre les jeunes
en garde contre les dangers de la
pornographie concernant ses fonctions
laissez-moi terminé que le sexe n'est
pas anodin et là on banalise les
rapports sexuels on banalise pardon mais
les fenêtres de la française dans sa
bouche ça sert postés partout sur un
tailleur film et je ne parle même pas
des enfants non voyants la beauté on
sent quand même la mettre de côté pour
son talent
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu ça j'ai découvert ça y'a pas
longtemps voilà goûter jong il ya
quelques mois sur les réseaux rage et
moi j'ai pas envie parce que j'ai
vraiment très curieux d'essayer mais pas
comme ça pas maintenant tout au plus
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fini il n'y a pas d'heure pour un
plaisir à ma joue pas mais pas la mer
mais pas de quoi vous voulez l'arrangé
toujours invaincus
à
ah ben si maintenant elle est terminée
donc non pardon
c'est
oui c'est très très bon eh ouais non
mais ça a l'air bon ça vous plaît c'est
très bon joueur mais une deuxième
vague août et encore ils appellent ça
fait longtemps
installé dans
la
vie
c'est plus intéressant
on s'en fout un peu alors ça veut dire
bon salaire bon c'est quoi ces deux là
tu te tapes un pegi me doutais avoue
benoît ramade et claire quoi gilles
peut-être et non c'est
moi j'ai tout si vous voulez nominé
alors vous pensez qu'il faut interdire
aussi ne bien sûr la barre au graphique
on protège nos enfants via des réseaux
sociaux et de tout ce qui s'y passe et
là on les expose franchement à des
scènes qui sont extrêmement paix dont
profite s'est vendu sa cavité où aussi
bien cher plus tard et c'est la
déconfiture est unanime et mathieu la
manuelle on adore la censure je ne le
sais très bonne idée arrêtée tunisienne
tout et tu mets tous mes yeux vo pardon
mais il ya vraiment évidemment une
différence entre détenir par exemple des
images pédopornographiques et aller
acheter un petit zizi ans
c'est à dire que et guillaume du toit
vous êtes en train d' associer le sexe à
la de la pornographie et gap et nous
faire dans la foule énorme paquet 12h30
est ouvert
oui c'est très beau mais c'est que c'est
plate l'amour le sexe est patent en
production le sexe est très beau ça
m'énerve de voir des influences euse
kick it is like qui se la joue féministe
août la journée kim est acquitté de la
wii
c'est bon c'est la question très bon
alors et rien que pour la qualité du
produit moi je pense qu'il faut pas
interdire les quatre îles très bon bah
oui jean chapet boule orange la peine
circoncis
[Rires]
ces regards à l'après montrent un bond à
fine c'est ça la fait vraiment moi je
vais réunir après avoir gardé la balle
au bond la fin quoi il réussit son
talent tout en plaisir
samara benhaim jeunes de parler là
je ne vous ferai pas une charisme je ne
me rappelais bon la chérir par ce
concept les spectateurs car sinon dit la
fin voilà oui mais non
c'est rigolo je veux partir dernier kate
bordel